are we in a recession or are we not and
how much more has to happen for it to be
official the first estimate of the us's
gdp in q2 showed a 0.9 percent decline
combined with the report for q1 this
means the first half of 2022 has seen
negative growth two quarters of negative
growth is a good rule of thumb for
identifying a recession but the national
bureau of economic research or nber
makes the final call
essentially there's a good chance we're
in a recession but here's why we can't
be sure just yet the nber has to
consider three things before making the
call
the first is duration which is likely
met now that we know we've seen six
months of negative growth for the us
economy
the second is death the depth of the
decline remains a key question with
declines in economic growth around one
to two percent this year this is
actually considered a shallow decline
recessions can often see an economy
decline around five percent or more
the third is diffusion the most complex
of the three parts of the nber's
definition
some sectors of the economy such as
travel and energy are doing relatively
well right now but we've also seen big
swings in trade and some slowing down in
retail automotive and housing
often recessions happen even as some
sectors boom for example during the 70s
and 80s the economy hit several
recessions but the energy industry did
relatively well throughout but the
question for the remainder of the year
is whether inflation comes down
significantly and if economic growth
resumes
you